[Musique]
le déclic je les ai eues il ya très très
longtemps il ya une
une trentaine d'années quand j'ai
commencé dans la restauration où je
faisais mes glaces et
quand j'ai toujours aimé faire ça et ce
qui fait que j'ai voulu nous faire mon
métier à plein temps
[Musique]
on se démarque fondamentalement par la
qualité et par le pourcentage de matière
que l'on à l'intérieur
très vivement que vous avez 1 70%
demande à l'intérieur du
à l'intérieur de la glace le reste est
composé d'un sirop qui est composé le
sucre et d'eau il n'y a rien d'autre
[Musique]
quand j'ai repris cette belle entreprise
j'avais vraiment à coeur de pouvoir donc
offrir à tous des produits donc avec une
traçabilité
et que le consommateur puisse réellement
savoir ce qui allait avoir dans son
assiette
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
métro est un vrai partenaire pour pour
les restaurateurs est donc c'est
vraiment un billet un biais qu'on veut
utiliser pour se faire connaître et pour
augmenter notre chiffre d'affaires
auprès des restaurateurs de la région
[Musique]